you sure you're at the right party
this is a celebration for the saints is
it not
business with marshall is less lucrative
than it used to be
i was hoping your bosses would be
interested in a new partnership
[Music]
[Music]
they're in there i'd knock if i were you
hello
it's antonio espina
look i i know that we don't have the
best history
but i was thinking
hoping really
that we could work something out
[Music]
no rush by the way take your time
you are in for a world of pain
this is a vibe
pretty great if you ask me
this town is hours for the taking
right what's next then
time to settle older
something about this town lots of fire
in me
but
this game ain't gonna play itself
[Music]
antonio glad you came to your senses hey
i'm kind of having a party right now but
we'll talk business later
[Music]
we got a party going on so i'm gonna
keep this one short and sweet [ __ ] the
panteros [ __ ] the idols [ __ ] marshall
the saints are here to stay baby
so if you know how to shoot a gun or if
you're broke and want to learn how swing
by the church we'll be waiting for you
[Applause]
[Music]
hey guys
[Music]
why
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
hello and welcome to marshall defense
industries
we know it wasn't easy getting here your
journey began with one of the most
unforgiving job interviews we could
devise
but you did more than just survive a few
live fire exercises you excelled and in
doing so proved that you were martial
material but don't take my word for it
hear it from the man
himself hello i'm atticus marshall and i
wanted to personally welcome you to the
marshall family here at mdi we don't
just make a problem we make the world a
better place
so how do we do that
with a little tlc
technologically advanced weapons loose
morals and a culture of conflict
now let's take a step through each of
those letters
why are you watching that now it's the
orientation video i know what it is why
are you watching it now well i mean
we're about to be shot at so i figured
it couldn't hurt to brush up on our
health care package if you weren't
paying attention to the briefing i don't
think you'll live long enough for your
copay to matter so i should be reviewing
the life insurance policy you know our
job interview has a 5 mortality rate
statistically the odds were low that you
would die before we hired you but i
allowed myself to be an optimist your
parents should have treated you better
yours should have treated you worse
all right ladies and gentlemen contrary
to your colleague's demeanor this is no
laughing matter the nuali already took
out one team that was sent to bring him
in and i want as many of us going home
as possible so stick to the plan work
together and let's grab that son of a
[ __ ] and send him to the frontier
let's get paid
[Music]
alpha team go first day on the job the
[ __ ] up
ketchup right let's kick some holy [ __ ]
turrets take cover
that was close
jesus christ my first [ __ ] day
[ __ ]
anybody left me i think
we have to rendezvous with bravo team
but we're dead keep pushing forward i'll
meet you there copy that welcome to the
daily grind
project
that helps
hey you we gotta find [ __ ]
better hustle newbie robo team is ready
to move in i'm not exactly taking a
coffee break here
marshall scum oh bite me
you still alive you sound like you lost
the pool fall in we'll use this apc for
cover the rolling shield nice now i'm
delighted you approve bailey make a hole
roger that
now let's go through the
go go go
keep it up team let them have it yeah
you guys [ __ ] with the wrong
multinational private military
corporation
hey this may be a weird time to ask but
do we get hazard pay you get a
performance bonus for outstanding work
if you survive to collect it got it
trying to understand the pay structure
bailey hold up marshall clear the field
yes man
[ __ ]
take the turret i got it i'm good with
these no that's not you are damn lucky
we don't have time to argue
told you i was good with these
take it out before it cuts down
you all right bailey bailey get your
foot off the gas
whoa oh [ __ ]
gwen gwen can you hear me anybody
[Applause]
[ __ ] either they're all dead or there's
no signal
push on and find in a walley myself
the things we do
this one's asking for it
where are you hiding
at least they don't have to wear a suit
oh
finally the end of the tunnel
gwen hello do you read me no you're
still alive yeah i hear that a lot the
nawali's hold up in the saloon up ahead
rendezvous with the rest of us and we
can box him in in a minute gonna clear
out some goons first i gave you an order
it's on my way besides we don't want him
coming up behind us later fine but next
time i give an order the only words i
want to hear are yes and ma'am got that
uh yes ma'am
gotta earn that performance bonus
feels good to make an honest living
little c4 should take out that barricade
couldn't do that at my last job
be over here
glad you could join us let's move we got
to keep the nuali hold up until charlie
team arrives
movie once we hit the saloon you flank
left while the rest of us hold the
center blank but i can
yes ma'am
saloons right around this bend get ready
and remember the plan
all right team let's take it
see i'm blinking left as ordered
down fighting oh come on it's my first
[ __ ] day
black soldiers charlie team is here sit
back and let us wrap this up nice timing
perimeter secure yeah that's probably
because of my flanking uh-huh now get in
there and flush that son of a [ __ ] out
[Music]
what does it take for a man to be able
to enjoy a quiet drink these days
mr nawali you're coming with me
you really think you have what it takes
to bring me in
i mean
yeah
hey where you [ __ ] going i said
you're coming with me
perhaps i don't respect your authority
then respect this you set one foot on
those stairs
holy [ __ ]
no you goddamn don't
[Music]
give it up nawali there's nowhere to
hide
you're surrounded take it easy on
yourself
[Music]
what the
i can't find him never mind get back
here and recruit we've got the bastard
bottled up with nowhere to run
we know he's in the saloon he can't stay
in there forever
what the [ __ ] thanks for the ride
i'll see you around
we need air support now
stand down we don't got time for hero
[ __ ] don't worry got this
gwen we've got a problem hang on the
cavalry's coming
oh [ __ ]
come out with your hands up
not today
let's take them out boys
when hurry can barely get a beat on
these guys no there's only someone that
told you to stand the [ __ ] down
hold this thing still so i can kill your
guys
oh
we're gonna have fun
oh
yeah
oh
you have more courage than brains
goddamn right
you're too predictable
am i
[Music]
you tried i'll give you that get your
hands in the air
i caught him